Benjamin Netanyahu says he will fight to
stay in power after becoming the first
sitting Prime Minister in Israel's
history to be indicted on criminal
charges Netanyahu faces allegations of
fraud breach of public trust and bribery
Roxana Saberi is tracking the story from
London Roxana what else is the Prime
Minister saying well he's calling the
allegations an attempted coup but
Israel's Attorney General says no one is
above law Netanyahu is accused of
granting political favors in exchange
for more positive news coverage and
pricey gifts like pink champagne and
cigars the indictment is embolden
Annette in Yahoo's rivals they say it's
impossible for him to rule wife while
facing criminal charges but he enjoys
strong support from the White House the
Trump administration has reversed
decades of US policy by recognizing
Jerusalem as Israel's capital as well as
Israeli settlements in the West Bank and
the Golan Heights then Yahoo is vowing
to keep leading the country and under
Israeli law he can stay in office until
a final verdict Gail even if he's
eventually convicted the appeals process
could take years
all right Roxanna thank you very much